[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 78
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre émission
football l'équipe senior de l'Étoile
Sportive de trappe s'est imposé à
domicile ce dimanche contre sarcell sur
le score de 2 buts à 0 un match frisé
qui permet aux ivelinois de s'emparer de
la 3e place le résumé du match dans ce
magazine ultimate coup de projecteur à
suivre sur le club zéogène de plaisir la
structure créée en 1997 contte une
quarantaine de licenciés nous recevrons
dans quelques instants sur ce plateau le
président et joueur Arna parents et
l'entraîneur Jacques Bénard tir à l'arc
un atelier était organisé ce samedi au
gymnase Auguste de Laune de manilamo
l'événement était programmé dans le
cadre de la Semaine femme du monde CIN
débutants plus essayer à ce sport
reportage à suivre et puis nous
parlerons également de Tumbling un sport
originaire des États-Unis affilé à la
Fédération Française de
Gymnastique on commence ce magazine par
du football l'équipe senior de l'Étoile
Sportive de Trapp s'est imposée à domile
ce dimanche contre sarcell sur le score
de 2 buts à 0 cette 8e victoire de la
saison permet aux hommes d'Arnaud mbz de
reprendre la 3e place le montage est
signé romain
rini l'Étoile Sportive de Trapp remporte
le choc de cette 15e journée du
championnat de Promotion d'Honneur des
oranges 3è avant la rencontre se sont
imposé de buts à 0 contre le 4e Sarcel
un succèsquis dès la première période
avec de buts inscrits dans les 45
premières minutes les appliqu et puis
inves dans dans ce match du jour malgré
en fait début match un peu compliqué on
a su la bar et pu faire preuve de
maîtrise mérité on a fait un très très
bon match on est en place on a créé du
bon jeu on a eu des occasions on les a
on les a marqué et et voilà le résultat
est est satisfaisant après une première
période maîtrisée les trapiste ont
baisser le pied en seconde période pour
conserver le résultat ça dev pousser un
peu donc on un peu subi mais c'était
maîtrisé quoi dansensemble c'est un
match satisfaisant on a des occasions
bon bon pe on a relâché parce que le
fait qu'on marqué on était à 2-0 on
pouvait tuer le match pour rester sur le
podium trap devra s'imposer le dimanche
20 mars sur le terrain descant une
équipe qui à la 8e place du
classement après le football on passe à
un autre sport qui mêle les passes et la
technique
l'Ultimate une fois n'est pas coutume
dans cette émission nous allons parler
d'Ultimate frisbe et plus précisément du
club zérogène la structure a été créée
en 1997 et compte désormais des équipes
en National 3 pour nous parler du club
nous avons le plaisir de recevoir sur ce
plateau Arnau Paran le président et
Jacques Benard l'entraîneur au club
bonsoir messieurs bonsoir bonjour alors
tout d'abord est-ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter l'Ultimate
Frisbey oui bien sûr ultimate Frisbey
c'est un sport qui vient des États-Unis
euh qui se joue sur un terrain de foot
en 7 contre 7 il faut amener le frisbe
dans une zone d'en but alors c'est c'est
ça nous fait un point commun avec le le
rugby fautmener le ballon dans la zone
d' but et le football américain sauf que
là les passes peuvent se faire en avant
en arrière mais toujours le joueur qui
fait la passe est arrêté tous les autres
joueurs S sont attaquant doivent se
libérer pour avoir le Frisbey sis sont
défenseurs doivent intercepter le frisbe
pour à leur tour attaquer et c'est un
sport accessible à tout le monde
exactement euh dans le club on est on a
des licenciés qui sont entre qui ont
entre 14 et 45 ans je pense euh des des
hommes des femmes donc vraiment vraiment
à tout le monde on a quelques
expérimenté des personnes qui ont fondé
le club donc depuis 97 jouent euh
quasiment 20 ans et puis des débutants
qui ont commencé en cours d'année au
mois de je pense que les derniers c'est
au mois de janvier et comment
expliquezvous que ce sport si populaire
aux États-Unis le sport est pratiqué
quasiment par par tous les Américains
c'est le 4e sport national aux
États-Unis dans les universités alors
qu'en France cette discipline peine
encore à s'imposer comment
expliquez-vous cette différence
certainement parce que le le sport est
américain donc il a été inventé là-bas
il y a une certaine passion pour ce
sport aux États-Unis et peut-être qu'en
France on est trop attaché au au sport
traditionnel on a du mal à à s'ouvrir
des nouveaux sports donc c'est c'est
vraiment on on on gagne à être connu
c'est-à-dire que les euh comme dit euh
Jacques on a beaucoup de de nouveaux qui
arrivent même en janvier euh les gens
essayent et généralement ils restent il
ils accrochent donc il faut faire le
premier pas généralement çapp çapp
beaucoup ouais oui ou oui parce que
c'est on est facile d'accès déjà on est
facile d'accès parce qu'on est un club
sympa et puis on est facile d'accès
parce que euh comme disait Jacques fille
et garçon déjà on est mixte et euh et de
7 à 60 17 ans alors c'est c'est pas vrai
il nous il a bien précisé de 14 à 45
mais tout le monde peut venir jouer et
comme c'est nouveau il y a pas cette
barrière si si vous venez si vous venez
dans un club de de football et vous
allez jamais jouer au football vous
allez vous sentir un petit
peu pas votre place peut-être là le
frisbe bah faut pas s'inquiéter moi j'en
fais depuis depuis 10 ans je suis un des
anciens en loisir également aussi
peut-être la section loisir peut
permettre justement de développer ce
sportû c'est tout à fait
euh mais on insiste quand même nous on
pense que le frisbe est sympa quand il
est joué en en championnat donc on on
même nos nos jeunes nos jeunes moins
jeunes loisir on les amène en
championnat et justement ils accrochent
encore plus généralement et ce sport est
essentiellement basé sur le fairplay
également ce qui change de beaucoup de
sport oui oui les les les bases mêmees
du sport sont sont sur le le fairplay
donc les règles ont été écrites dans ce
sens et tout se se fait donc sans
arbitre sur le sur le sur le terrain
c'est le seul sport collectif sans
arbitre et donc tous
les cette ambiance de de match est est
très est facilité et facilité par cette
absence d'arbitre et c'est ces
discussions juste entre joueurs pour
valider ou non une faute une faute ou un
point ça permet d'avoir cette voilà
c'est cette ambiance je ça ça donne une
bonne ambiance ce faire et donc ça se
passe comment si deux joueurs ne sont
pas d'accord sur sur une décision donc
s'ils sont pas d'accord sur une décision
on revient on fait machine arrière de
quelques secondes donc on revient à la
passe d'avant et on reprend le jeu à ce
moment-là et donc il y a également des
compétitions et votre club évolue en
National 3 alors oui le club évolution
en National 3 alors il y a des
compétitions National 2 tout à fait
c'est là je vouis venir donc il y a des
compétitions extérieur intérieure la
saison intérieure est finie c'est la
saison d'hiver et cette année le le
l'équipe une euh à gagn le le
championnat national 3 donc évoluera
l'année prochaine en National 2 pour
l'extérieur on est encore National 3 le
championnat va va va bientôt arriver
d'ailleurs on on
l'organisera et ben on est encore en
National 3 hein mais peut-être peut-être
qu'on va aussi faire enfin l'exploit
c'est pas l'exploit mais réussir à
gagner ce ce championnat et le club peut
monter encore plus haut euh bien là que
le club a des des pépites des Jeur qui
faire la différence c'est c'est pas
évident parce que je pense qu' Mo
National 2 faudra faudra digérer le
nouveau le le nouveau le niveau qui est
bien meilleur en National 2 on a connu
la National 2 on est descendution 3
assez récemment et on sait que le niveau
de plus en plus fort comme comme vous le
disiez c'est un sport qui monte donc il
y a de plus en plus de de très bonnes
équipes
euh nous on a notre niveau qui qu'on
connaît qui est assez bon
et ça serait prétentieux de dire que on
peut monter facilement mais on en a
l'ambition en tout cas et qu'est-ce
qu'il vous faut pour pour monter
justement peut-être plus de moyens euh
plus de moyens je pense que pas vraiment
des moyens je pense que la balle est
dans notre camp et par exemple cette
année on a voulu monter une section
jeune par qu'on est aujourd'hui on a une
section pour tout le monde et on peut
pas vraiment inclure les les très jeunes
et on pense que l'évolution de notre
club passera par les les plus jeunes
donc je je dis certainement que l'année
prochaine on réouvrira une section jeune
et que inscrivez tous vos jeunes à à
plaisir à l' teammate et et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il est il est là c'est le
le il y a un terroir qui est présent à
terroir tout fait il faut qu'on inclue
des nouveaux jeunes parce que on a une
très bonne équipe d'expérimentés mais
qui vieillit et on a du mal à renouveler
donc on voudrait on voudrait vraiment
inclure les plus jeunes et créer une
dynamique et vous organisez également
des compétitions le le zeropen va
souffler cette année sa 12e bougie
est-ce que voilà l'Ultimate la
popularité de l'Ultimate pass passe par
ce type de rendez-vous bien sûr les les
les tournois comme le zer open
permettent
d'accueillir du des des joueurs
différents des compétitions et
l'ambiance tournoi est est très très
sympa et les gens ont envie de rejouer
et donc peuvent venir à s'inscrire dans
un club Le Nôtre ou d'autres de France
pour pour jouer à l'Ultimate combien de
joueurs participent à la compétition on
a h équipes de à peu près 10 personnes
donc ça va faire 80 80 personnes et le
public peut venir assister à cette
compétition bien sûr bien sûr au Palais
des Sports le 16 les 16 et 17 avril
prochain venez découvrir l'Ultimate dans
le donc c'est la grande salle de de
plaisir il y a de la place pour tout le
monde vous inquiétez pas il y aura une
petite buvette mais il y aura surtout
des des très beaux matchs d'Ultimate à à
voir en 30 secondes est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner envie de de rejoindre
votre club zérogène notre club alors
pour citer un un des membres fondateurs
du club pour jouer à l'Ultimate pour
jouer àog il faut être sympa donc ça do
vous donner envie de venir on est on est
ouvert à tous les les les les filles les
garçons venez vous vous verrez euh tout
âge alors tout âge je vais dire allez à
partir de 14 ans et puis dès l'année
prochaine à partir de de de 10 12 ans on
aura notre section à nouveau c'est bon
30 secondes parfait vous me laissez
annoncer le allez-y excusez-moi donc on
on a le Z0 Pun qui sera le le le 16 16
et 17 avril et la semaine d'après 23 24
avril si je trompe ça tombe le weekend
aussi c'est le deuxème weekend des
vacances il y aura les championnats de
franceational 3 en extérieur à hlencour
au stade Boniface le stade de de rugby
je sais pas exactement par qu'il y a y a
le le foot juste à côté donc au stade de
rugby Boniface venez voir du du très
haut niveau national 3 ultimate à
hlencour noté merci à vous deux d'être
passé sur ce plateau on continuera à
vous suivre à suivre votre club et on
viendra également au tournoi Z0 P du
coup au mois d'avril après l'Ultimate
nous allons parler à tir
àarc
un atelier de tir àarc était organisé ce
samedi au gymnase Auguste de laone de
Manil l'événement été programmé dans le
cadre de la Semaine femme du monde c
débutants ont pu s'essayer à ce sport
Patrick Jacques de dixmud pour les
images j'ai tout tiré du même côté mais
ça va je m'en suis sorti quand même
Yvette habitante de manilamoau découvre
le tir à l'arc pour la première fois la
retraitée manikois s'est inscrite ce
samedi à cet atelier organisé par la
ville au gymnase Auguste de un événement
programmé dans le cadre de la 10e
édition de la Semaine femme du monde TR
encadrant ét présent pour coacher les
débutants tout d'abord c'est la
compréhension du geste l'activité tir
àarc est une activité de
concentration et donc on va demander au
personnes de se concentrer de rester
dans la cible et bien évidemment on a
tout un volet qui concerne l'activité
sécurité au total 5 nois se sont
inscrits pour ce rendez-vous m tir à
l'art c'était une occasion c'était pour
faire un essai c'est sympa je
connaissais pas du tout et je dois dire
que ouais c'est sympa c'est physique he
quand même donc on sent que ça travaille
hein c'est c'est plus physique que je ne
pensais cet atelier d'initiation
pourrait susciter des vocations chez les
participants la compagnie d'arc de
maniléamo qui compte à ce jour 108
adhérents on recensera peut-être 5 de
plus en septembre prochain après cette
séance
découverte
aujourd'hui le 78 Sport vous propose de
découvrir le tom link ce sport
originaire des états-unisun discipline
affiliée à la Fédération Française de
Gymnastique les tumblers doivent
enchaîner des acrobaties sur une piste
de 25 m de long pour nous parler de
cette discipline nous recevons sur ce
plateau René ebami coach de la section
tumbling depuis 1990 pour le club des
clés sous-bois responsable des équipes
de France junior depuis 2001 et vous
avez également amené plus de 100
athlètes au championnat de France et une
dizaine d'athlètes en en compétition
internationale bonsoir tout à fait
bonsoir alors nous recevons également
sur ce plateau les tumblers Axel duriz
Matthéo curté et également Matis
boursier alors tout d'abord est-ce qu'
vous pouvez nous présenter le tomling
renez donc le tomling est est un sport
acrobatique qui se déroule sur une piste
qui fait 25 m de long sur 1,50 de large
le but est d'enchaîner des figures
acrobatiques avec des rotations
longitudinales qui sont des rotations V
et des rotations transversales qui sont
des rotations salto il font les exécuter
au nombre de H dont la dernière est la
figure la plus aérienne parce que c'est
la la figure qui pctue la série et
quelle est la différence avec la
gymnastique classique donc ce sont deux
sports qui on peut dire qu' sont qui
sont issus de la même famille à partir
ce sont des sports acrobatiques la seule
différence c'est que donc on peut
assimiler pour faire une meilleure
comparaison on peut parler on peut
comparer la le tbling au à la GR qui est
la GR gymnastique le sol vous savez ce
fameux sol avec un tapis où où on fait
des rond flic des salt sur une surface
qui est moins rebondissante que la piste
notre piste est quand même plus
d'élastique donc la différence ça sera
une prise de vitesse plus grande
c'est-à-dire que le but du tomling c'est
de d'amasser une certaine une certaine
vitesse et d'enchaîner des figures
acrobatistes le plus vite et le plus
haut possible et en gymnastique ça sera
de réaliser des figures acrobatiques
mais sur deux à trois éléments grand max
et généralement un bon gymnaste peut
devenir un bon Tumler pas du tout c'est
c'est qu'on peut penser justement dans
c'est il y a eu des bonnes reconversions
il y a des gymnastes qui qui qui on qui
ont fait des des médailles
internationales mais il y en a d'autres
qui ont essayé qui n'ont jamais pu parce
que justement la vitesse la prise de
vitesse n'est pas une chose que les
gymnastes arrivent à gérer et donc pour
certains ça va ça va trop vite si bien
que leur leur compétences en matière
d'acrobatie ils arrivent pas à faire la
corrélation pour pour le mettre sur une
piste donc du coup on n pas forcément
bon gymnaste et bon tombleur Matthéo
qu'est-ce qui t'a attiré toi pour dans
dans le Tumling bah c'est pour LAN dans
ce sport c'est le fait d'avoir l'IST
d'acrobatie j'aime bien tout ce qui est
acrobatique et tout et j'aime bien les
sensations avir la tête à l'envers et
tout et tout même chose pour toi euh moi
j'aime bien aussi oui j'aime bien tout
ce qu'il y a de
l'action on fait des saltos j'ai
toujours rêvé de faire des saltos je me
disais est-ce queil y a un sport on fait
des saltos et finalement je l'ai trouvé
ce sport et déjà j'ai une superbe équipe
un super ou donc j'ai beaucoup de chance
il va être sélectionné pour le prochain
rende-v c'est ça c'est gentil alors qu
enfin quel muscle travaille le plus du
coup dans dans le
Tumling plus les abdominaux jambes
jambes les jambes c'est c'est un sport
de rebond c'est un sport où il faut
c'est-à-dire qu'on recherche chez un
tumbler les critères pour pouvoir dire
il peut être bon c'est c'est c'est le
rebond donc les robbond qui dit rebond
10 jambes donc ça veut dire d'avoir de
très bonnes cuisses de très bons molets
et c'est la partie musculaire qu'on
qu'on qu'on muscle le plus mais il ne
faut pas négliger les abdominaux ni les
bras parce que les bras intervennent
quand même mais vous m'avez demandé le
plus gros muscle je vous dis c'est les
jambes vous qui avez l'habitude de
détecter les les nouveaux talents
comment reconnaît-on un bon Tumblr ben
c'est ce que je vous dis par
c'est-à-dire je prends un exemple c'est
Axel Axel si jamais je ne l'avais pas
fait je l'aurais jamais connu lors d'un
d'un centre de loisir enfin d'un d'un
d'une journée porte ouverte que j'ai
organisé pour les centre de loisir j'ai
eu plein de jeunes de son de son âge et
lui il ne connaait même pas le tombling
ni la gymnastique conna sait rien et là
je do j'ai fait des petits tests comme
ça justement de rebond c'està dire je
demander des éléments simples accroupis
sur extension une hauteur sautée du sol
sur sur une hauteur on voit les
facilités et donc il avait donc une
capacité de rebond qui était
extraordinaire je lu dit toi je pense
que appelle ta mère tu dois faire du
tumbling et je me suis pas trompé parce
que 2 ans après voilà 2 ans après
c'était c'est un un tumblerné quoi il
est vraiment doué pour ça Axel quand on
voit cette discipline on remarque que
c'est ultra spectaculaire à la limite du
dangereux toi ça ne te fait pas peur non
pas trop parce qu'il faut faire surtout
attention surtout attention ou et même
tes parents je sais pas qu'est-ce qu'il
pensent tes parents de du fait que tu
sois Tumblr bah c'est bien déjà parce
que c'est un bon sport
et bah ils aiment bien ça en tout cas ok
toi tu t'es pas blessé si je me suis
blessé mais pas gravement gravement
ok le tomling c'est dangereux ou
pas ce n'est pas du tout pour moi ce
n'est pas dangereux du tout mais pas
pour moi pour tout le monde mais c'est
c'est vrai que souvent comme c'est un
sport qui est très spectaculaire ça veut
dire que ça monte très haut et on défie
les lois de la pesanteur c'est quand
même c'est ça qui qui nous fait adhérer
à ce sport là parce qu'on on aime
justement ce ce défi justement où
l'homme n'est pas fait pour êre ta tête
en bas et nous on passe TR qu TR qu4 du
temps sur la série la tête passe souvent
par le bas donc on peut se dire ouais si
jamais il a chute sur la tête mais c'est
comme tout sport il y a des prérequis
les prérequis sont euh sont sont bien
gérés il y a pas de problème pour qu'
accident ça veut dire que je dis il faut
bien être encadrer les gamins leur
prendre conscience que en effet si on a
tê en bas on peut Tom sur la tête et on
sait très bien que tomber sur la tête
c'est pour l'être humain c'est pas très
agréable donc juste fair prendre
conscience qu' on on ne tente pas des
figure que l'entraîneur n'a pas n'a pas
conseillé donc à partir moment eux le
savent euh ils n'ont jamais fait une
figure qui qui même s'il la voit qu'ils
aimeraient la faire ils attendre que
jeun le feu vert pour la pour commencer
à la réaliser tout seul il faut jamais
mathtis tu confirmes oui ce n'est pas
dangereux du tout le timing bah déjà il
faut faut écouter l'entraîneur s'il y a
quelque chose qu'on fait mais il nous
l'a pas dit de faire ça peut être très
dangereux parce que des fois il y a des
figures que j'aimerais bien faire mais
euh faut que j'attende la permission de
du coach donc bien avir les conseils du
coach avant de de se lancer bien sûr
parce que voilà mais ce n'est pas
dangereux du tout parce que comme je
vous ai dit je vous l'ai dit je je n'ai
pas de beaucoup de blessures à déplorer
comparé au au nombre de temps qui passe
sur la piste euh voilà il s'est fait une
petite entorse comme je disais la
blessure c une entorse comme on entorse
au foot en courant donc c'est fait une
entorse la jeis voilà un arrêt de 15
jours et puis sinon pourtant il passe
plus de 15 heures sur une piste par
semaine donc c'est pas un sport
dangereux non le département des il ne
compte que trois clubs comment
l'expliquez-vous c'est un sport qui est
jeune parce que si on regarde le foot
j'ai pas les les années en tête mais je
sais que c'est beaucoup plus vieux que
ça nous on le Ting arrive dans
l'Hexagone
euh au début des années 70 donc il y a à
peine 45 ans donc au niveau au niveau
connaissance du sport ben faut que le
temps que ça se passe deuxième raison on
n'est pas olympique et je pense que les
sports olympiques sont beaucoup plus
médiatisés n on n pas médiatisé donc les
gens les personnes ne sont pas au
courant de que la discipline existe et
en général quand les gens quand les
personnes les enfants surtout réalisent
que ce sport existe en général voilà il
suffit simplement de leur parler de leur
montrer et je pense qu'on peut faire
beaucoup d'adeptes mais voilà et le fait
que pas médiatisé et qu' so pour
olympique faire en sorte que le sport
encore un un peu méc dans dans le
territoire et la troisème raison
excusez-moi c'est aussi pour une
histoire d'installation c'estàdire que
notre piste fait 44 m de long au total
piste d'lan piste dévolution et
réception 44 m il n'y a pas beaucoup de
gymnases des gymnases en France qui ont
une telle salle donc quand on veut créer
ces sport là il faut avir les dimensions
du gymnas de 44 m de long et ça c'est
sont RAR donc en général c'est difficile
de trouver et au club des clés vous avez
quelques champion quelques champions oui
c'éit un club qui marche bien et j'en
suis fier et c'est grâce à eux parce que
voilà on peut leur faire confiance voilà
non c'est un club qui marche bien voilà
Matthéo tu te sens bien dans ce club tu
veux rester encore quelques années oui
bah le temps que je fasse du Tim et ce
club peut encore progresser selon vous
René bien sûr parce que moi je suis à la
quête du progrès j'ai des objectifs
c'est-à-dire que j'ai des tites de de
champion de France j'en ai plein des
participations championnat du monde et
des médailles internationales j'en ai
aussi mais le le titre suprême serait de
j'arrêterai ma carrière quand j'aurai
peut-être un jeune qui sera sur une la
plus haute marche du du podium au niveau
des championnat du monde voilà c'est là
il y en a peut-être un sur ce plateau
actuellement il y en a trois il y en a
trois c'est noté en tout cas merci à
tous les cas d'être passés sur ce
plateau bon courage pour la suite de la
saison on passe maintenant à
l'essentielle de l'actualité
sportive on commence cette dernière
rubrique par de l'aviron les régades de
Versailles une compétition centenaire
était organisée ce dimanche sur le grand
canal du château organisé tous les 2 ans
le rendez-vous a attiré plus de 1200
rameurs de 35 clubs les sportifs sont
venus de la région parisienne de camp de
Ran de compienne et même de Turin en
Italie on écoute l'organisateur Jacques
Beck il était au micro de Patrick
Jacques de dixmut les rameurs ont de de
de 12 13 ans à au
vétéran sans limite d'âge il y a pas de
d'enjeu sur il y a pas de sélection sur
ces courses c'est simplement une course
de début de saison mais qui permet
d'étalonner quand même les équipes parce
que les les équipages vainqueurs à
Versailles sont souvent sur les podiums
nationaux en fin de
saison dans la catégorie FS4 versaill
équipage grignac a terminé à la 2e place
dans la finale A derrière Joinville le
club de la cité royale a terminé premier
dans la finale B du FS 8+ avec
l'équipage braconnier devant compienne
et Turin on passe à la boxe on avait
quitté le verrieroi Ahmed elmoussaou
dans les cordes après sa défaite contre
l'Australien Jeff on l'a retrouvé
victorieux ce samedi à Levallois peré
dans la soirée baptisée fight and
Furious le boxeur francomarocain a
remporté son combat de reprise au Palais
des Sport Marcel Serdan à Levallois le
prince a battu au point FOAD el massoui
dans la catégorie des pois Welter deux
juges ont donné la victoire à Ahmed El
moussaou et un juge à donné match nul
après cette victoire le boxeur
cquantinois devrait tenter de remporter
les combats à l' International dans les
prochains mois on on continue dans la
boxe mais cette fois-ci éducative Jordan
dwick s'est imposé lors des finales
interrégional ce weekend dans la
catégorie des cadets moins de 86 kg il
est désormais sélectionné pour les
finales à fourmis dans le Nord la
compétition r lieu ce samedi 19 mars si
le boxeur verrierois remporte sa finale
il sera qualifié pour les championnats
de France à noter également la
qualification de keniron dans la
catégorie moins de 57 kg et de Sacha
Martinovic chez les cadets moins de 68
kg de l'escrime à présent est Stre
Guyard originaire du vziné dans le nord
des Yvelines a décroché son billet pour
les Jeux olympiques de Rio en battant la
champion olympique en titre l'italienne
Elisa di Francesca 15 à 10 Astrid
Guillard s'est ensuite incliné en car
contre la Russe Diana Yakovleva pour
l'instant quatre équipes sont qualifiées
pour les Jos et 14 tireurs pour les
épreuves individuelles un mot de
football le PSG peut laisser éclater sa
joie les joueurs qui s'entraînent à
Saint-Germain enlé dans les iblines ont
été sacrés champion de France dès la 30e
journée un record les Parisiens se sont
imposés 9 buts à 0 sur le terrain de 3
avec un quadruplé du suédois Zlatan
Ibrahimovic avec 20 25 points d'avance
sur Monaco le PSG ne peut plus être
rattrapé et remporte donc son 6e titre
de champion son 4e consécutif le le
roordman de victoires en championnat
reste l'Olympique de Marseille avec 11
titres remportés et on termine par un
rendez-vous le tournoi international
junior féminin de handball qualificatif
pour les championnats du monde 2016 en
réussie est organisé de ce vend à partir
de ce vendredi 18 à ce dimanche 20 mars
au Palais des Sports Pierre de Coubertin
un plaisir la France l'Israël la
Macédoine et la Slovénie s'affronteront
dans ce mini tour pour gagner leur
billet pour la compétition seule la
première place est qualificative c'est
la fin de ce 78 sport merci d'avoir
suivi passé une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur TVfil